and you get spray lysol spray some lysol
after the door closes we have boots on
the ground right now yes
boots on the ground it's going down
[Music]
well this is great guys i can't wait to
meet
antoinette's family hopefully they're
nice
and we're all on one accord right guys
and if anything does
go awry it's all for one and one for
all if things don't go well in the
philippines it's going to be
a thriller in manila
are you with me are you down who's not
with me
if you're not with me get up get out the
van
right now as a family we're going to
stay in manila for a few days before we
arrive at anginet's village
oh we're here already we're definitely
going to take in
some of the sites and kind of learn
engineer's culture a little bit yeah
come on binky good time
cece time and manila
after be 24 hours but we've made it
i'm so tired oh my gosh
what your feet smell i smell them now
that i leaned down
here i've been 24 hours with the same
shoes put on my feet did you wear socks
that's the first problem the moment that
you took your shoes off
the room filled with nacho cheese
dorito smell we
you know it was a little mistake that
was a little mistake i've been saying
fumes winky that was weird maybe
it was for the mary for the weather for
the humidity that's happening in
philippines because that never happened
before don't blame it on the philippines
[Music]